[Music]
hello there reject nation
looks like that gosh darn robert
pattinson
in his little batman movie his cousin
so much drama out there in the world of
warner brothers still
to this day it's almost as if these
channels that do movie news
weirdly their movie news only being
dramatic movie news
they needed a conflict that they need in
this movie
to have production delays and drama in
order to
thrive right well yeah every production
delay is just an opportunity
to showcase what potential drama could
be behind that
i think some people are really under
this misconception when they come to our
videos
that if we are simply talking about
a leak or rumor it's true i believe it
people think
just that that we think that when
in reality what we do is we we go
through it assess
way out some stuff probe it and i feel
like most of the time we walk out going
no i don't believe it really in life it
sounds like bs
they're fun to cover though they are fun
to talk about i think they're they think
they're amusing and because this is the
batman
you know we're gonna get people coming
our way but basically here's the deal
guys the rumor
is and got this off of bounding into
comics.com saw this circulating around
because let's face it batman will be in
the real rejects algorithm search feed
all over google and social media warner
brothers thinks the batman is terrible
and may delay it again to 2023
okay good let's see why
this article is saying this these have
all been so ridiculous
the batman could yet again be in serious
trouble as according to a new rumor the
film has been the
subject of frustration and negativity
all the way to the top
of warner brothers studio c senor
of course none other the source close to
youtube scooper
dictor von doom [ __ ] tells the future
ruler of earth that the bloated and
beleaguered production could face
another delay and in the process become
the most expensive movie
ever made more than evan almighty i
don't think so
john take that what does that say ooh at
the top of the discussion about this
rumor it should first be noted that even
doomcock himself is stressed he is
skeptical about the information he
presented
and urged viewers to take it with the
usual grain of salt
that's reassuring that is especially
coming from duke
yeah it's a kid with a korean assault
man i mean his videos are entertaining i
gotta admit even though 99
of the time i don't believe regardless
the word from his source
is that the villains vexing the dark
knight this time
our studio executives this was the most
dramatic
weighty word the villains vexing the
dark knight this time are studio
executives who've seen the movie and are
of course not happy
okay so that's what's what it is all
right i mean that could be
real we've seen that brother a lot of
times with warner brothers and there's
movie studios all the time and even
before
wb got like a very public reputation for
doing that
they had been doing that yeah okay we
gotta be fair
maybe maybe possible following the
wrapping of filming in march matt reeves
reportedly screened a rough cut of the
film for studio executives
after which they freaked no this movie's
torah
as noted by doom [ __ ] the reaction was
similar to those of star wars and star
trek fans who saw the last jedi
and into darkness you know i
you see you could do this with any movie
any movie you could do this with so they
screened a rough cut pick any upcoming
movie you want a name
and they could just easily go studio
exacts freaked no specific studio exacts
freaked right like they don't say which
ones they just got to say studio
executives
freaked and fans who were disappointed
with other franchises before
liking it to kind of this experience
it's really easy to do that especially
with a franchise as big
and with as much mythology as this one
yeah it's just like
when it's wb like they've wb has clearly
created
a reputation for themselves and uh i
would say like they've kind of made an
enemy out of a lot of
fans pretty obvious unless you're
godzilla yes
but even with godzilla there was some
crap that was going on uh all the
champion restoring the snyder burst and
such
so yeah we'll see i mean i
like a heated shouting match
oh yes and then they just completely
lost any believability
there a shouting match allegedly ensued
between the execs
shocked by the [ __ ] they watched and
reeves who struck back at the very same
executives who didn't listen to his
previous complaints about robert
pattinson
oh okay fair enough you know if they
really didn't want to keep robber houses
so no i don't believe this
i mean how how how much can you clash
with your own star i don't know
i mean it's happened for sure but it
seems like it was written
out of a comic book you know like a
movie you know what big movies
will do in situations where it's this
heavy of a dis especially if it's a
heated shouting match they're saying
it's between two
between the execs right reeves got
involved in this argument and started
got participated and said shouting match
i think that
you know we've seen it like rogue one
we've seen it with justice league we've
seen it so maybe they're like
oh after replacing a director with
justice league we can't do that again
maybe sure there's always a possibility
that something is going wrong
just because studios are have this
happen to them
warner brothers has definitely had this
happen
and right now i could see a scenario
where warner brothers is like
very much you know we got this whole
slanted vase fan base it keeps coming
down on us whenever we put out anything
i feel like there's also the other
arguments
who goes i don't think they really even
care about that yeah
so i don't think it's true surprisingly
despite the stories about the former
twilight star's failure to work out and
bulk up his
aliens with co-stars zoe kravitz his
attitude on the set and how awful he
looked in the suit next to the stunt
players
the studio's problem is apparently with
the film's bruce wayne stuff
huh interesting spin doom [ __ ] hears the
action scenes are
fine per se because the action was cool
in the trailer so you can see absolutely
like that yeah because there's evidence
but the producers are mulling the
possibility of reshooting the scenes of
pattinson as the billionaire playboy
for whatever reason though the shouting
match was the reason i feel like that is
so
like if anything that would be the bruce
wayne stuff you could easily pull off
absolutely yeah you don't need to do
much you've seen rubber bands
yeah apparently are the least expensive
parts to film again and warner has the
budget very much on their minds
the batman so goes the intel is
ballooned to a cost of nearly 400
million dollars and wb wants more to
show for it than a cut of their losses
by dropping in theaters and hbo max as
is they're not going to drop this on hbo
max well no
this is the biggest thing arguably on
their horizon why would they do that
especially like it's still a ways off
anyway
i think after 2021 seeing that midway
through 2021 the theaters are
bouncing back pretty strong even with
a couple of their own movies like mortal
kombat and godzilla versus kong
next year they're gonna go we're not
doing that
not hbo max thing you're gonna be sure
they've already said like that was only
for 2020 yeah and we're not doing that
anymore
dupe [ __ ] adds it while bad movies get
released all the time the batman must be
a special kind of terrible given how
it's drawn such a nuclear reaction of
ire
good word again this scoop could be
another one of the tinfoil hat crowd but
it sure makes it sound like warner is
regretting
letting zack snyder go and then there's
the agenda right here
lucky for them there may still be a time
and a demand to restore it and this
is why these stories are things are
getting pushed
it just ends right here what do you know
that's not the way to restore this
you know we're champions of the snyder
but i also want to see this batman movie
be awesome
and i feel like they've been trying to
take this movie down with the weirdest
behind-the-scenes drama they could just
just conjure up yeah matt reeves is
unprofessional and crazy and robert
pattinson doesn't care
i think any one of these news stories
really i mean like there was this
the comment that pattinson made about
the working out which got
him in some trouble because he did that
in an actual interview and said that but
i'm pretty sure there was like a
sarcastic edge
to what he was doing yeah but everything
else
by now a legitimate like a variety holly
reporter deadline
they would have gotten a hold of one of
these things if it was actually true
yeah yeah well the other thing is didn't
robert pattinson just sign a first
look deal with hbo or wb or somebody in
that family over there if they hated him
that much or worse
that's a strong point man also at the
end of the day what they'll want
is uh as long as they can keep getting
good trailers out of it
and knowing they'll sell tickets for it
because trailers speak
much louder volumes than anything else
they're going to be sending their ways
anyway guys what do you think do you
believe this
leave your thoughts down below is the
batman in trouble
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button feel free to recommend any other
stories our way that sound like a fun
time going through